always kissing me oh it's kissing me
always kissing me he loves me and I love
him
I had ducks before but it is it doesn't
seem like they appreciate it to be quite
honest I remember one time I thought the
duck a whole piece of bread he ate the
whole piece of bread
birds are fine I guess I don't really
have any I don't watch birds I don't
care about ducks like I've seen baby
ducks on Instagram and they get like mad
likes so let's go meet the duck I'm
nervous
I hear them squeaking
so soft and so like brittle this duck is
just full of surprises
oh he's doing stuff I need I need you
guys sorry I I just you not used to
seeing the little baby animals guy
yeah I'm not I'm not ready to have a
duck I'd be nervous to turn on a light
switch right now I just I feel happier
like the rest of my day is gonna be
better
life is a miracle it's a miracle like we
all evolved from like little things but
like you see it and you just like you
want it to be okay can I hold them again
actually
[Music]
innocent people noises pleaseno goes
peepee he goes peepee